مره اخرى يخاطب قيس سعيد التونسيين من
داخل احداث ثكنات تزامنا مع تمديد حاله
الطوارئ في البلاد حتى نهايه العامه يهدد
الرئيس كذبه ويتوعد من يصفهم في كل مره
بالخونه والمتامرين دون ان يسميهم مطالبا
بمحاسبتهم خطاب التهديد والوعيدي فهم هذه
المره على انه موجه ضمنا للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الاكبر نقابه البلاد
يتولون اليوم التهديد بقطع الطريق السياره
لا يمكن ان يبقوا خارج دائره المساءله
الحق النقابي مضمون بده سور
ولكن
الحق النقبي لا يمكن ان يتحول الى غطاء
لمارب سياسيه لم تعد تخفى على احد
كلامه سعيد تلاهم مباشره اعتقال مسؤول
نقابي دعا الى الاضراب واغلاق طريق السريع
وسبقه تعيين نقبي معارض لقياده الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل كوزير للتربيه فيما
بدا اشاره لا تخطئها العين الى المنظمه
النقابيه وفق مراقبين دفع هذا التصعيد
الهيكل النقابي الى اجتماع عاجل لمكتبه
التنفيذي اعتبر عاقبه في بيان انما حدث
ياتي ضمن ما وصفها بمحاولات تجييش ضد
الاتحاد لمنعه من لعب ما وصفه بدوره
التاريخي في انقاذ البلاد من ازماتها
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه لاسيما
وانه يعد مبادره للانقاذ كما دعا
النقابيين للتعبئه والاستعداد للدفاع عن
الحق النقابي والحريات العامه والفرديه
بكل الاشكال الممكنه على حد وصفه
المعارضه من جهتها ترى في كلام سعيد نزعه
انتقاميه وسعي لتصفيه خصومه عبر تخويمهم
كما تقول وتضيف ان خطاب سعيد الاخير يمثل
محاوله لتغطيه علامه سمتها الانتخابات
الفاشله بعد ما قطع الشعب هو
اليوم
ربما تراى له انه عندما يذهب الى سكنه
عسكريه او ساكنه بوليسيه المعارضه تخاف
والنقابل ستخاف وايضا الشعب التونسي سيخف
ولكن اعتقد ان الخوف نسيناه منذ 2001
اي بوادر لحلها
بتصريحات والتلميحات بين سعيد ومعارضه
يعيش المواطنون تحت وطئ في مصاعد اجتماعته
واقتصاديه
متلاحقه خاصه من ربح الجزيره تونس